[Music]
pokemon scarlet and violet are the
latest mainline pokemon games and the
first two announced for gen 9. it's
exciting and there's extremely little
that we know about the new games but
there is a lot we hope to see that's why
we compiled together nine things we want
to see in pokemon scarlet and violet
some are pretty plausible while others
might be a bit out there but a fan can
dream right so like the vid sub to the
channel for updates as they come in
we would love to see a lot of gen 1
throwbacks or references the new region
is supposedly inspired by spain a
country that's far away from real life
kanto japan but we'd like to see pokemon
embrace its og roots a bit the franchise
has evolved significantly since the old
days maybe giving us a retro radio to
listen to some old gen 1 tunes or having
other references to pokemon trainer red
would be cool a bunch of the older games
actually let you battle red and i would
love to see that again in gen 9.
we've got plenty of end game guides all
ready for pokemon brilliant diamonds
shining pearl and legends arceus on our
channel and both games have a consistent
thread in common with their end games
they're very linear objectives that can
be summed up basically by catching all
the legendaries and by extension
completing your pokedex i don't expect
this to change in gen 9 but i'd like it
to because it would be cool to see an
endgame that has a much greater variety
of activities whether it be solo or
through online connectivity my favorite
which might be unpopular actually it's
gen 3's contests i i would love to see
those return although i know it's
unlikely i know certain activities that
you could play in the end game like
those contests do appear again in later
versions but i'm telling you right now
gen 3 was the best also gold silver
crystal are the only pokemon games that
stashed an entire extra region in the
end game it's tough to reasonably expect
something like that again especially in
how today's games are marketed right
because if we ever got to see multiple
regents in a new pokemon game it would
most likely be because of paid
post-launch dlc that being said a guy
can still dream and in the perfect world
i would love to see a second region
being kalos
after all kalos is loosely inspired by
france which neighbor spain so
potentially in the pokemon games the two
regions would be neighbors as well i
know this probably isn't gonna happen
you can save the comments for this part
and you'll just have to excuse me
because i'm gonna go down a rabbit hole
of copium
this is one element we can almost be
certain will return it is something i at
least hope returns as the lack of pvp
and legends arceus was upsetting even if
it made sense from a story perspective
pvp keeps the mainline pokemon games
alive once you've beaten the main
campaign and potentially complete your
pokedex there's something obsessively
fun about stockpiling powerful mods
min-maxing their stats and coordinating
battle moves for a strategic team
even just having trainer and gym battles
returning will be a delight i'm
definitely hoping to battle some of my
friends when scarlet and violet comes
out i'm not a competitive battle expert
but our former gamespot pokemon experts
jake decker and cali plaguey teamed up
for some awesome high-level competitive
battling videos on our channel that you
should absolutely check out you might
learn something new
all right call me old man dave here but
the newer takes on gym battles such as
sun and moon's island trials aren't my
fancy but maybe scarlet and violet can
appease my desire for the older classic
pokemon style with some twists because i
appreciate a developer's desire for
change and wanting to inject some flair
and novelty into a pretty admittedly
rote system but i've been playing the
mainline games for so long that i've
grown fond of that kind of basic
structure if anything i'd rather see gym
leaders with a wider variety of battle
strategies than crutching on a single
predictable type for example instead of
having a rock water or fighting gym
leader or any of the other 18 types that
are out there we could have one with a
variety of types but specializing in a
team that uses a strategy like trick
room or baton pass in gen 8 the dragon
gym leader ryhan is a superb example
here he only really uses two dragon type
pokemon with half of his team being
non-dragon types but he uses them to
control the weather as a strategy his
gym is also similar to a set of leaders
in ruby and sapphire where their gym
battle was based around psychic double
battles these kinds of variety packaged
in the traditional gym battle would be
an awesome trait that gen 9 could use
oh man if you've never
never played ruby or sapphire you missed
out secret bases were an incredibly fun
cosmetic gimmick that you could do on
the side and it was easily one of my
favorites there are modern versions of
sharing spaces with friends yeah whether
it be the union room or the grand
underground however secret bases were
better in my opinion the number of dolls
and cushions and trampolines and fun
structures you could create was an
excellent pastime and customizing your
space was cool as ever gen 3 secret
bases were so sick because they allowed
you to essentially create your own kind
of gym sharing your info with your
friends would hide your secret base in
their world and if your friends found
your base and managed to make their way
through whatever you used to decorate it
they could find an npc with your party
of pokemon and then they could challenge
you earning money and experience if they
managed to win it was so cool
[Music]
legends arceus turned pokemon into
somewhat of an open game from a pve
point of view it was incredible the
gameplay loop was strong and had a lot
of fun exploration and mystery having
this kind of feedback and letting you
catch wild pokemon seamlessly either
right off the bat with berries as bait
or through battling is something that i
would love to see taking the open world
a step further though and letting
players explore or discover different
parts of the region at their own
discretion would be a radical step for
pokemon this is extremely unlikely since
a huge part of the core loop in the main
storylines is unlocking hm certain moves
or some kind of a variant like the noble
pokemon or legends arceus with the
purpose of granting you access to the
later areas in the main game we saw the
possibility of unrestricted exploration
with the beginning steps in a pokemon
game like legends arceus it would be
awesome to see gen 9 build from this
first step and run with it
[Music]
alright not to sound toxic but we can
all agree that with sword and shield and
onward the graphics for pokemon have
been
questionable part of me wants to blame
the switch hardware and there's a lot of
frustration with nintendo's awful online
infrastructure compared to something
like xbox live or ps plus however poor
optimization is definitely on game freak
it would be nice to get a pokemon game
that doesn't look like it belongs on a
gamecube i mean i've been able to look
past this with legends arceus because
the novelty of that game was just so
strong but i'm not sure if i could do it
again
with sword and shield and legends arceus
there have been many cutscenes and story
beats and right now it feels a little
odd with having these cutscenes or
dialogue sequences but without any voice
acting personally if we're going to go
the cutscene route it would be nice to
get full on voice actors in gen 9. if
nothing else maybe it's worth going the
hybrid approach like fire emblem or
breath of the wild where not every line
is spoken aloud instead some sounds or
expressions are conveyed to help make
less important scenes feel more alive
while full-on voiceover can be
exclusively saved for important
narrative moments plus it would help
make the game more accessible for folks
who struggle with reading subtitles i do
appreciate however legends arceus giving
us akari my absolute favorite
later generations have added to the
national decks by giving older pokemon
new evolutions or baby forms for example
in gen 2 we got numerous new baby
pokemon like ella kid togepi magby and
more we also got new final evolutions
like slow king polytoad or steelix there
have been some gimmicks like mega
evolutions dynamaxx gigantomax and
region specific forms such as the alolan
sandslash or ninetails these changes are
fun for a time but i personally prefer
having permanent evolutions for pokemon
and i would love to see older pokemon
get these evolutions of course i'm
excited to see a whole new swath of
pokemon to add to the national decks
with the three starters strongly
grabbing my attention but i don't want
to see some of the doper pokemon from
past games just be forgotten and left in
the dust
we don't know a lot about pokemon
scarlet and violet but this here looks
like a great one for pokemon use stick
around as we'll let you know right away
as we learn more about pokemon and gen
9. in the meantime check out our videos
on legends arceus or brilliant diamond
and shining pearl until next time
[Music]
you